[Musique]
bienvenue dans la grande interview pour
un entretien exclusif avec simone gbagbo
l épouse de l'ancien président laurent
gbagbo jugé par la cpi pour crimes
contre l'humanité lors de la crise post
électorale en 2010 il a été acquitté
mais reste en attente d'un procès en
appel
avec lui elle a fondé le front populaire
ivoirien dont elle est la vice
présidente madame gbagbo
merci beaucoup d'avoir accepté
l'invitation d'arreter france mais s'il
ya l'allemagne 2 mai dernier
madame gbagbo après votre arrestation
avec votre époux laurent gbagbo en 2011
vous avez passé sept ans en détention en
résidence surveillée cette élection
présidentielle de 2002 en côte d'ivoire
c'est l'occasion pour vous on le voit
bien de reprendre vos activités
politiques
et quelles sont vos motivations
premières choses et je ne reprends pas
mes activités politiques maintenant je
suis sortie de prison de 8 août 2010 8
depuis cette époque là je suis sur le
terrain je mène des activités politiques
donc je ne repars pas mon activité je
voulais l'aider à le plaisir de masse
depuis l'annnonce de la candidature
d'alassane dramane ouattara pour un
troisième mandat c'est vrai que vous
êtes sur le terrain
c'est ce que je voulais dire un petit
peu vous êtes sur le terrain vous allez
à la rencontre de vos militants très
activement pour quelles raisons mais
disons qu'au départ jallet sur les deux
puits 2018 dans le cadre normal des
activités politiques pour renouer avec
des ailettes renouer avec mes militants
avaient quand même je suis resté sept
ans après cela il fallait reprendre le
contact avec eux et donc ça m'a permis
de tourner dans de nombreuses localités
à l'intérieur du pays abuja même
excellent mais aujourd'hui nous sommes
en période électorale et
une crise qui était prévisible est
arrivé dans notre pays est à ce moment
ci tout le monde s'active pour essayer
de sortir le pays de la crise de sortir
le pays pour lui permettre de redevenir
un état vraiment démocratique
et c'est cela que nous occupe à ce
moment-ci il ya aussi donc ce troisième
mandat que brigue l'actuel président qui
pose problème à de nombreux ivoiriens à
l'opposition ne m'en parle pas savez
nous avons une constitution d'un autre
pays
nous avons un code électoral également
dans notre pays et c'est deux textes
sont très claires si le fait que
quelqu'un qui est au pouvoir a pu
bénéficier de deux mandats et bien au
bout de ses deux mandats il est obligé
d'arrêter cette clairement inscrit dans
le texte et à la scie plus générale le
chef d'état actuel décidé de briguer un
troisième mandat personne n'est d'accord
l'asean est d'accord et c'est cela qui
fait le débat aujourd'hui le pays
justement connaît d'un cycle de violence
de tension très inquiétant à la proche
du scrutin programmé le 31 octobre
est ce que réellement vous pensez que
les ivoiriens sont prêts à revivre une
crise similaire à la crise post
électorale qu'ils ont connu en 2010 et
qui a fait 3000 morts
les mois à venir je vous assure un
madame n'ont jamais souhaité vivre dans
la crise ni aujourd'huiet les ivoiriens
que je connais ne sont pas déjà perdu
que violain et c'est là mais il se
trouve que des gens ou de raison du
désordre au prince pour des raisons d'
ambition politique
c'est ça qui fait la queue c'est ça qui
a fait la crise de 2002 à 2010 où ils
ont tenu à organiser une rébellion
divisé le pays en deux
rentrer dans des maisons tuer des gens
et caetera et aujourd'hui nous sommes
encore dans cette punition la
constitution il doit bien lui doit être
respecté le code électoral ivoirien doit
être respectée
voilà ce que nous disons maintenant du
zoo soul à ceux qui sont en face qui ne
veulent pas se qui a pas c'est qui qui
viennent qui frappe nos militants qu'il
blesse le militant et c'est ça que vous
appelez la crise ivoirienne
les ivoiriennes ne sont pas pour que ce
monsieur la brigue un troisième mandat
ça c'est clair vous avez cité la crise
de 2002 celle que votre pays connaît
actuellement vous avez omis quand même
la crise de 2010 lorsque vous et votre
mari était au pouvoir
mais l'atout de 2002 mon mari est un
pouvoir c'est cette crise là qui est
allé jusqu'à 2010 bombardier tôt pour
moi il est arrivé au pouvoir en 2000 et
il est au pouvoir quand un groupe armé
qui se constitue et venir attaquer de
régime avec les deux du support
étrangers des nations nous accepter la
cette crise-là qui a perduré jusqu'en
2010 non je ne l'oublient pas je
l'inclus sur les violences actuelles on
assiste à des tensions
intercommunautaires des violences
intercommunautaires comment vous
l'expliquez 1 alors qu'il ya eu tout un
processus de réconciliation nationale au
monde
est ce que google est ce que vous avez
vu la réconciliation nationale en côte
d'ivoire
justement c'est ça le problème
le problème c'est que de 2002 à 2010 le
pays a été divisé en deux et de toutes
pièces de paraty on a créé une position
entre le nord et le sud du pays
on a créé une opposition entre les
chrétiens et les musulmans dans ce pays
est énorme
cette division là elles perdurent elles
existent encore dans les esprits
c'est pour ça qu'il est tellement
important de procéder de prendre le
temps de parler avec les gens pour
obtenir la réconciliation
ce n'est pas encore fait ce n'est pas
encore acquis et tant que ça ne sera pas
acquis le moins de problèmes dégénère
dérape et de générer facilement à un
conduit à quelle communauté et c'est à
cela que nous assistons surtout 4 on en
vient instrumentaliser les ethnies
instrumentaliser les tribus n'est ce pas
pour en faire des défenseurs de sa cause
alors justement quand vous pensez y
amène la violence quand vous dites
instrumentaliser les les ces violences
le le pouvoir accuse justement
l'opposition l'opposition renvoient la
balle du côté du pouvoir
donc c'est nous qui croire mais oui mais
je n'ai observé la situation google et
vous vous vous aurez rapidement la
solution à ce problème la télé les les
ivoiriens et ceux de l'opposition
appellent à descendre dans le rue ils
descendent dans la rue pour manifester
mais ceux qui descendent pu manifester
descendent et ils manifestent les menus
ceux qui instrumentalisent tanger du 10
et du mental et technique c'est qu'ils
prennent déjà deux communautés malinké
ou de communautés du nord il les met
dans des tentes et abris les mettre dans
des dina dinah cdd petit état du 18
place du vin place et cetera
est il utile et il m'aide de ville en
ville pour attaquer les manifestants
attaqué les masseurs avec des matchs est
avec des couteaux et qui blesse les gens
qui poignarde les gens qui égorgent même
des gens qui possèdent à des enlèvements
d'opposants et c'est pendant ces temps
de pouvoir lui même avec ses policiers
avec ces gendarmes avec ses juges
procède à des enlèvements procèdent à
des arrestations
voilà alors la violence se moukila
subissions que vous venez à un accès
un petit peu la situation dans le pays
vous d'attirer le vous même vos propres
conclusions
madame gbagbo est ce que comme
l'opposition vous maintenez votre appel
au boycott actif est la désobéissance
civile pour le scrutin présidentiel du
31 octobre
alors je voudrais encore préciser
quelque chose l'opposition n'a pas
appelé au boycott n'appelons pas du tout
au boycott des élections du 31 octobre
nous disant qu'il ne faut pas qu'il y
ait des élections parce que la condition
pour obtenir des élections justes
transparentes inclusives ne sont pas
réunies et que tant que ces conditions
ne sont pas réunies
il est une ineptie départ il n'est pas
correct et il n'est pas juste que nous
tenions des élections en cette nation
sinon nous là nous nous sommes peut-être
la fin des élections nous voulons des
élections
nous voulons un scrutin présidentiel un
petit par mes patins les policiers
mais le pouvoir n'a pas l'intention de
toutes façons de reporter ce scrutin et
il ya dans l'opposition certains
appellent leurs militants à empêcher les
opérations de vote
est-ce que vous lancerez un appel dans
ce sens également à vos militants
nous moi je me suis associé à l'appel de
la désobéissance civile et je pense que
tout ce qu'il faut être tout ce qui doit
être fait pour que ces élections là soit
reportée et que l'on s'asseye pour
régler le problème il faut le faire et
c'est pour ça que même grâce à votre
micro je réitère ma demande à ce pouvoir
qu'il organise rapide de mach de
reporter les élections parce que
maintenant c'est trop tard et qui
organise rapidement une table ronde
pendant laquelle les questions votre vie
sur la place et cela sous la table et
voir extractif et les listes électorales
de la soit auditée que le découpage
électoral s'établissent de façon
consensuelle mais à farinia tout le
monde a droit aujourd'hui
opposition madame gbagbo il n'y a pas de
report d'une irritation elle sauvé grâce
à des militants
il ne peut pas d'élections aujourd'hui
je ne peux pas avoir dans ce pays
d'élection aujourd'hui et si si la
situation dégénère
une fois que le pouvoir l'entente dix
fois que le pouvoir de comprennent
aujourd'hui là si nous voulons que la
sécurité revienne et la vie des
ivoiriens soient préservés une fois
qu'ils reportent saisis ainsi que dans
la cei et que l'on discute sommes des
adultes et que l'on traite les questions
qui sont apportées et si la situation
dégénère madame mac vous êtes vous
assuré au l'opposition assumera sa part
de responsabilité c'est la situation
dégénère quelle est la responsabilité de
l'opposition dans sept ans quelle est la
responsabilité d'une position dans cette
demande aux gens ce qu'ils voient rien à
dire ils sont civile madame greg bear
express que le pouvoir est prêt à
entendre ce que l'opposition demande
depuis des mois depuis deux mois je
dirais même depuis des années parce que
moi je suis sorti depuis six ans en 2018
mais depuis 2018 cette question là est
sur la table aujourd'hui demander aux
pouvoirs qu'elle prenne ses
responsabilités pour une fois de faire
en sorte que les gens puissent se
manifester sans qui viennent est
agressée et qu'ils convoient il convoque
une table ronde que les gens ça c'est
que les gens discutent à que les gens ne
se sont pas assis que les gens ne
discuterons pas une aura de problèmes
dans sa vie alors symbole de la cédéao
la communauté des états d'afrique de
l'ouest demandent à l'opposition de
renoncer à son appel au boycott et à la
désobéissance civile que lui répondez
vous j'ai eu ma réponse
ce que là ce que je vous ai dit tout à
l'heure la l'opposition n'a pas de n'a
pas appelé au boycott
le positionne du mal que des élections
soient reportées et que l'on s'asseye et
que l'on traite les questions qui
concernent l'ordre
la fin de cette élection si la cedeao
que dans ce prix que ce soit pour
traiter cette question si la cedeao
n'est pas capable de tout et c'est alors
qu'elle est restée chez elle
madame gbagbo on va marquer une courte
pause et on va poursuivre dans un
instant restez avec nous sur rt france
[Musique]
retour dans la grande interview avec cet
entretien exclusif
madame gbagbo simone gbagbo la vice
président du front populaire ivoirien
est notre invité on parlait avec vous
madame gbagbo de la cedeao est ce que
vous estimez que l'organisation ouest
africaine prend parti dans cette
élection présidentielle en faveur
d'alassane dramane ouattara
moi je sais pas ce que vous savez de la
cedeao
c'est une grande institution qui
rassemble tous les pays afrique de
l'ouest
qalqilya ils l'utilisent comme cela et
qu'elle intervient ce qui est légitime
mais qui est légitime
il est temps que l le courage d'entendre
chacun chacune des parties peut le dire
ce qui est la vérité et de dire ce qui
est le droit de regarder où il y à des
fautes et et d'appâter vrai que chaque
pays est souverain et donc la cedeao
même à un pouvoir d'action qui est
limité à cause de la souveraineté de
chaque état
mais tant que head vient intervenir pour
aider à régler un conflit
la première chose qu'on va lui demander
quel de courage de regarder la vérité en
face et de dire la vérité dans ce cas ci
la halle je suis je suis malheureusement
se désole mais la cedeao déjà venu est
intervenu à plusieurs reprises d' assez
pour que ce débat si que nous menons et
la cda ne nous a pas beaucoup aidé parce
que de plus de position là ne sont pas
deux ne sont pas fondées ni sur la
justice ne leur est pas même de l'autre
ni même sur le respect même de ce que ce
qui est leur valeur en afrique un peu
cheap et désolé de constater cela mais
c'est pas alors pour revenir à la
troisième mandat d'alassane dramane
ouattara j'ai une question puisque
laurent gbagbo il a dirigé la côte
d'ivoire presque onze années de 2001 à
en quoi finalement la candidature de
laurent gbagbo qui a été déposé par ses
partisans est rejetée elle aurait été
plus légitime que celle du président
actuel mais le la constitution
ivoirienne digne que quand vous êtes
pouvoir vous devez faire des mandats
mais c'est gbagbo n'a pas fait deux
mandats il a fait un mandat et au moment
où il voulait organiser les élections
pour le deuxième mandat
il y a eu des débats il ya eu une
rébellion dans ce pays et la vie
politique il va aller a été bloqué
pendant cinq ans il a fallu beaucoup de
négociations beaucoup du d'entregent
extra puis finalement les élections ont
été organisées en 2010 à 2010 quand les
élections ont été organisées
les résultats ont été proclamés
et au lieu de laisser monsieur gbagbo
fait tranquillement son deuxième mandat
il y a eu l'intervention militaire de la
france et de l'onu pour imposer au
pouvoir mais alassane ouattara non mais
c'est pas qu'on n'a pas fait deux
mandats
voilà c'est ça le problème
vous vous demandez l'amnistié le retour
de laurent gbagbo qui est toujours à
bruxelles en attendent un procès en
appel depuis son acquittement par la cpi
est ce que vous avez pu en discuter avec
le président alassane ouattara
donc moi je n'ai pas discuté avec le
président alassane ouattara mais
l'opposition lui a posé des problèmes
les parties lui a posé des problèmes
voilà c'est pas moi en tant qu'individu
qui quoi pourquoi ce retour est
impossible à ta femme et tes alassane
ouattara qu'il faut poser la question
c'est quoi votre avis
moi mon avis j'ai observent ils ne
veulent pas le laisser rentrer je ne
comprends pas pourquoi il n'y a aucune
raison pour que monsieur monsieur
ouattara refuse de délivrer un passeport
à monsieur gbagbo il ya autrement il n'y
a aucune raison pour qu'ils puissent
justifier la donbass à lui il faut
plutôt poser la question vous pensez
qu'il y aura des négociations des
conditions qui seront posées à cette
retour et puis peut-être une amnistie
moi j'aimerais bien voir que quelqu'un
veuille imposer des conditions à musique
bagout son rituel en côte d'ivoire les
abattent un citoyen une vague il a été
déporté à l'ail pour un procès qui un
procès inique
un procès qui n'aurait jamais dû se
tenir nulle part dans le monde et ce
procès s'est tenu
et à l'issue de ce procès il a été
déclaré non coupable a quitté et avec la
possibilité de retourner chez lui
pourquoi est-ce qu'on va bene lui
imposer des conditions je comprends pas
alors il y en a d'autres qui attendent
leur retour et à charles blé goudé et
puis aussi guillaume soro sur guillaume
soro précisément est ce que vous vous
êtes réconcilier ce que vous lui avez
pardonné parce qu'il a joué un rôle
quand même important dans votre chute en
2011 à il a joué un rôle ex le même
porte est extrêmement grave a lui même
mis du sel il m'aime me laisser mais moi
je suis prête à à pardonnez moi je n'en
veux à personne je suis prête à
pardonner
donc je n'ai pas de problème particulier
avec lui mais lui il aura un problème
avec les iraniens
oui parce que même si on lui pardonne on
lui demandera qu'à même que du même de
présenter de demander pardon aux
ivoiriens de faire en sorte qu'il y ait
réparation de tous ceux qui tout ce qui
a été commise à paris le quai l'ex-chef
rebelle
vous avez été condamné à 20 ans de
prison pour atteinte à la sûreté de
l'état vous avez été annie sié vous
l'avais dit en 2018 par alassane dramane
ouattara vous avez passé sept ans en
résidence surveillée parlez nous un peu
de ces années madame gbagbo comment et
dans quelles conditions vous avez vécu
ses années de détention à ce que vous
avez pu prendre aussi du recul pendant
ces années sur les événements de 2010
notamment à garma je n'étais pas les
identifier
j'étais en prison voilà
mais sauf que je n'étais pas dans des
locaux de la prison d'odienné
mais on m'a mis dans une dans une villa
où j'ai habité pendant trois ans et demi
à odienné mais j'étais régie par le
régisseur de la prison du dîner et par
le procureur de djenné donc j'étais à
présent je ne sais pas
vous savez sur nous pour que vous soyez
en résidence surveillée il faut qu'il y
ait un décret n'est ce pas émis par le
chef de l'état voilà à l'époque on m'a
arrêté il n'y avait pas de chef des
temples du mois donc ceux qui m'ont mon
prix je considère que c'est un
enlèvement et je le redis d'ailleurs et
ça a été un enlèvement et qui m'ont
obligé à vivre à udine et puis après ils
sont entrés dans le processus judiciaire
normale où ils ont émis de matha des
dépôts et cetera et cetera
donc j'étais pas à résidence surveillée
qui est en prison maintenant pendant ces
trois sets un vécu j'ai eu le temps de
beaucoup réfléchir de soigner mon peu de
soigner mon élève de soigner mon esprit
j'ai tout ça est donc une alma jeanne
attirer de grands profits et c'est plus
simple aujourd'hui à la sortie j'ai pu
tant qu il m'a parlé et nécessité de
réconciliation dans notre pays quand
vous passez par ce diplôme a racheté par
votre coeur emprunt pour votre âme
emprunt ou votre emprunt coup et j'ai
passé vraiment est ces années-là à à
soigner tous
pourquoi pourquoi vous n'êtes pas
candidate pour cette élection
présidentielle en tant que vice
présidente du fpi vous aviez tous les
atouts finalement pour mener des
alliances et être la candidate du jef
pays oui mais qu'est ce que vous voulez
que j'aille faire un père candidate à
cette élection si la sallaz bateliers
direction l'important en ce moment si ce
n'est pas d'être candidat c'est le
candidat sa marque pas que tu vois
l'important ce n'est pas d'être candidat
l'important aujourd'hui battre pour que
la démocratie et dans ce combat là je
suis impliquée jusqu'au bout vous avez
des ambitions pour 2025
vous l'avez vous ne les cachais pas ses
ambitions bon on est là je ne traite pas
encore d un petit mois j'ai traître et
pillaient du vent - le problème qui est
devant moins c'est ce problème là que
j'ai truc à 2020 50 en 2025 on arrivé là
on décidera alors je voudrais qu'on
évoque l' affaire dite du braquage de la
bceao la banque centrale des états
d'afrique de l'ouest pendant la crise
post électorale de 2010 en 2011 pour
laquelle laurent gbagbo a été condamnée
d'ailleurs à 20 ans de prison
vous dites qu'il n'ya pas eu de braquage
mais plutôt vous faites allusion plutôt
à une réquisition de l'argent qui a
servi à payer ses fonctionnaires de dans
ce cas comment cela se déroulait est ce
qu'il ya des preuves de cette
réquisition est pourquoi les états
d'afrique de l'ouest n'ont pas porté
plainte
alors que cette banque elle leur
appartient aussi alors vous voyez bien
on voyait bien lorsque le pouvoir a
voulu convoquer ce procès là contre du
président gbagbo
la bceao a tout de suite élevé la voix
pour dire qu'elle ne considère pas du
tout qu'elle a été braquée quelque part
et donc elle n'a pas voulu s'associer à
ce projet voilà mais l'argent de la
bceao a servi à payer les fonctionnaires
comme chaque mois chaque mois pour
réaliser les dépenses de l'état l'argent
voit bien qu'ils aient abaissé à eau est
utilisée cesse à 16,7 dans les choses
dans les choses normales et et aidons
les fonctionnaires qui ont été payées
d'action là la somme de sandales
document toute la vie ça ne s'est pas
fait en cachette et le braquage pourquoi
parle-t-on de braquage est ce que c'est
le braquage est à déguiser ah ah voilà
papa le compte du braquage il faut poser
la question à ceux qui ont fait du
pousseur faut leur demander pourquoi 10
autorise à parler du braquage
pourquoi d'azur ci s'attend comme celle
là pourquoi ce qui parle de braquage
le chef de l'état a envoyé des gens à la
bceao chercher l'argent des ivoiriens
pourquoi parce qu à cette époque là à
cette époque là au niveau de la face
n'est ce pas comme au niveau des états
africains qui se tenait de la rébellion
ils ont voulu imposer que l'argent
ivoiriens ne soient pas mis à la
disposition du président gbagbo
madame gbagbo la france la france est
restée silencieuse face ce troisième
mandat que brigue alassane ouattara
silence que beaucoup jugent lourd de
sens pour le pouvoir mais aussi pour
l'opposition comment vous vous
interpréter ce silence moi j'écoute les
silences de l'argent de toute façon vous
savez la france avait passé silencieuse
que brûler dit l'autre que monsieur
alassane ouattara et en 2000 2018
quand il a dit qu'il ne voulait plus
qu'il n'allait pas être candidat partie
de l'article n'allait pas être candidat
mais le président français a fait 28 ou
le féliciter cette assiette mars 2000
fait d'ailleurs le le le
le président français a fait 28 ou le
féliciter et très bruyants ils étaient
très heureux que mais c'est à la salle
est décidé de ne pas briguer un
troisième mandat et puis quelques mois
après après toutes ses félicitations la
voilà monsieur alassane qui brigue un
troisième mandat et cathy brigue un
troisième mandat
le ministre des affaires étrangères
français je prends la parole pour
annoncer que monsieur alassane ouattara
a le droit de briguer un troisième
mandat alors que c'est une décision qui
piétine la constitution ivoirienne
c'est une décision qui qui qui est
insupportable qui est inacceptable
mais lui il a considéré que les médias
la femme avait le droit si je voulais de
briguer un troisième mandat donc voyez
que la france n'est pas sous silence est
la face n'est pas derrière une vie
encore il y a encore une déclaration une
dernière déclaration de monsieur jean
yves le drian
ces jours-ci qui revient contre la
décision qui a contrôlé la déclaration
la première déclaration qu'il avait
faite pour maintenant se rendre compte
que il y a des troubles dans ce pays et
que il faut que ces troubles a que là ça
fait fuir leurs règles ces troubles la
france n est pas n est pas silencieux de
ne pas s'élancer du tout merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup
madame gbagbo d'avoir participé à cette
grande interview merci pour cet
entretien exclusif une grande interview
que vous pouvez retrouver en podcast sur
nos réseaux sociaux et notre site
internet merci de votre attention et à
très bientôt
[Musique]
ici